はーいどなたですかちょっとだけいいです
か
おはようございますおはようございます何
ですかあのここの近所を回っていて皆さん
に聞いていますが日本語を勉強している人
たちはみんなアクセントがひどいのはなぜ
だと思いますか
いやあんまり考えたことないですねあでも
この現象についてどう思いますか
そんなにひどいと思わないんですけどねあ
でもそれは知識がないからなんですよ知識
がないとそう思っちゃうんですよだから皆
さんを
救いたくてここに行きました
すいません誰でしたっけアクセント
橋の道元と言いますが
そうなんですか
でも聞いたことありますよね
いやーんが
あーなるほどあでもこれが一番危ないん
ですよ
途中でロードマップをなくしてしまうと
迷っちゃうんですよ
Japanese
[音楽]
はいはいはいはいはいあのこれら全部悪魔
の学習法なんですよ
いやです
が頭高
そして平板が
とても可愛い子供ですね
彼のことを考えてみませんか
間違った発音を覚えてしまう前に正しい
知識を
与えてみませんか
重いじゃなくて重いそして赤いじゃなくて
赤い赤いっていう人はたくさんいますよね
あーまぁいますが間違ってますので
こんなにたくさんのルールを
守らなきゃいけないと思うと
息苦しくない
まあもちろんそういう時もありますがこれ
が正しい道だと分かっていますのでだって
例外と
矛盾
が多いんですよね